I believe that the PP should not help the government in anything that the
government looks for the problems that he himself has caused the
government to look for the sexual solution that is where he has got
involved And every time the popular party has made
state pacts and has thrown it at him,
he has proposed things to him,
the government has extended its hand to him because it has
discovered that wall in which the whole world is anti- and any
barbarity that the government agrees is at
least not governed by the right wing.
since now you have decided to lock yourself in your anti- wall,
let those who are supposed to be anti- help you
solve the problems that you yourself are causing.